هديه من روسيا بسخريه هكذا يصف لنا سكان
هذا المبنى القصف الروسي الذي اصاب بيوتهم
في الاول من ديسمبر
قد يكون في الليل او في النهار لا توجد
منشات عسكريه او استراتيجيه في نيكول هناك
مباني سكنيه ومدارس لا اعرف سبب استهداف
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد لا اعرف ماذا يدور
في عقولهم
الى داخل المبنى لمقابله السكان هنا
بلونين حجم الدمع والذي اصابقا
كنا في المطبخ عندما سقط الصاروخ الانفجار
كان هائلا تحطمت جميع النوافذ لا اعرف
لماذا يهاجمون المدنيين هذا ارهاب
جارته تماره في الثالثه والثمانين من
عمرها تعيش وحيده هي مصابه بمرض باركنسون
لا يمكنها مغادره المدينه يحرقها الياس
والغضب عندما تتحدث لنا عن ما حصل
ابدا
وانه بامكاني روسي ان ترتكبها هذا القدر
من البشاعه وان تاتي الى هنا لتدمرنا اين
هؤلاء الاخوه اذن لا استطيع ان افهمهم ولن
اسامحهم ابدا على كل الاشياء الفظيعه التي
فعلوها
شوارع
كانون الاول بارده وخاليه يغادرها بعض
سكانها ليلا للنوم في مكان امن ويعودون
اليها نار مواقع
على بعد خمسه كيلو مترات فقط من هنا
على الجهه الاخرى محطه النوويه التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الروسي تقصف مدينه نيكول منذ
الصيف الماضي بشكل مكثف ليلا وبشكل متقطع
نهاوند اكثر من 30 شخصا قتلوا في هذا
القصر
للجيش الروسي افضليه عسكريه في نيبو بول
فهي المدينه الاوكرانيه الوحيده التي
يقصفها ولا يستطيع الجيش الاوكراني الرد
خوفا من سقوط قذائفه على محطه ذا بويشا ما
قد يسببك كارثه النوويه